>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Aleksandra Dowdy: Hey
kids, how are you guys?
Welcome to the Library of
Congress Young Readers Center.
If you guys are here
from the Hill Preschool.
>> [children] Hi.
>> Aleksandra Dowdy: Hi, welcome.
It's so good to see you guys.
So today we have an author
with us, Ms. Alona Frankel.
She has written and illustrated
over 50 children's books,
and these books have been translated
into languages all over the world.
She lives in a country
called Israel.
Have you guys heard
of Israel before?
Have you been there?
She has traveled to us here, and
Israel is in the Middle East.
She's come a long way.
And she will actually
tell you where that is,
and Alona Frankel has also
designed and illustrated a lot
of books for other authors.
She has won many prizes for all the
amazing books that she's written,
and today, he's going to read
two of her books for you.
One is called Joshua's
Book of Manners,
and the other one is called
The Moon and The Stars,
and she's actually going to give
each and every kid here a copy
of the book, The Moon and The Stars.
Social read it for you, and
then you can take it home.
It's all yours.
And afterwards, after we read
these stories, you will be happy
to answer all of your
questions, okay.
>> Alona Frankel: Hi everybody.
It's so nice to see you.
You look for me from
here like flowers
and blooming and so beautiful.
So my name is Alona Frankel, and I
came from far, far away to tell you
about one of the books I
have written and illustrated.
If it seems to you
strange the way I speak,
is because English is not the
language of my country, and I may --
I can do some mistakes,
and I will be very happy
if you would tell you about it.
So I want to tell you that books,
they do not grow on trees, you know,
like apples or other fruits.
People the books, and the first
person that is responsible
for a book to be is the one
that wrote it, and I write books
for children, and the second one
is the one that illustrate it.
The illustrator.
I also illustrate books
for children.
One of my book is a book
about the moon and the stars.
And it's about a little girl.
Her name is Prudence, and her
best friend is a little dwarf
like this one.
You will see him all over the
book and this dwarf is my dwarf.
I like him very, very much,
and his name is Krasnoludek
[assumed spelling].
Can you say it?
It's difficult to say.
Try it. Kras-snow Lu-dick, and I
carried him always in my purse,
and when I feel uncomfortable or
something, so I just put my hand
in my person, and I feel
him, and I feel better.
I think that some of you also have a
favorite toy that you like to touch
and to feel that is your friend.
Okay, can somebody tell me
what toy is his favorite?
Like yours?
You have a favorite toy?
Which one?
Alligator while, but
alligators are scary.
So you must be very friendly, yes?
And -- well, he has a name?
Yeah? And do you have
a favorite toy?
Which one?
What is this toy?
>> Alligator.
>> Also an alligator.
>> Alona Frankel: Also alligator?
Well, alligators are so popular,
and do you have a favorite toy?
Which one?
What is it?
I don't hear you.
Can you come here and say that?
Come, come, get up and come.
Hi, what your name?
>> Amesa [assume spelling].
>> Alona Frankel: Ah, so nice.
So which -- and what is your toy?
You remember?
>> No.
>> Alona Frankel: What you toy?
A doll. Also alligator?
Also alligator, oh, my God.
Full of alligators, and who has
like a favorite toy like a bear?
>> Me!
>> Alona Frankel: You have a bear?
Or you have a bear?
Yes?
>> I do.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Alona Frankel: So
Krasnoludek is mine.
You will see him through all the
illustrations in this book I wrote
and I illustrated for
little children.
Oh, they fall over.
I put him here just
-- he's nice, huh?
I like it very much.
So now I want to try to read this
book for you, and you can look
up here, and you will
see the illustrations.
So first of all, I want to explain
why the name is moon and stars.
Because sometimes when I was a
little girl, and I wanted something
from my parents, so they
say, "No, we can't get you
because we do not have enough money
now, and the next thing you may wish
to have is the moon and the stars."
So it's completely impossible
to have moon and stars, yes?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yeah, what?
Come here.
You are so -- you, you, you.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Ah, that's exactly the same,
and the other little boy?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
No, you can't.
Come to me.
Oh, are so sweet.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
And what your name?
What your name?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
May I kiss your four head?
May I kiss you?
May I? May I kiss?
You like my necklace?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
It's bubbles.
>> Yeah.
>> Alona Frankel: Yeah, yeah.
Beautiful, yeah.
Okay, now you can sit and I can
start to read the book, okay?
Or you can stay nearby.
You can stay.
Do you want to stay with me?
Maybe you try.
Look, I'm very good grandmother.
Okay, so to your place, and
I will read the book for you.
So you can sit [inaudible].
[ Inaudible Speech ]
They are. They're very cute.
So The Moon and The Stars
written by Alona Franken.
It's me. So I am sure that you, if
you have a book that your parents
or kindergarten teacher or
whoever reads for you, a book,
so it's very important to
mention who wrote the book
and who illustrate the book, because
to make a book it takes many people.
Like first I told you the one that
is writing the book and the one
that illustrating the
book, and later,
the one who is printing the book,
and the person that's
selling the book in the store.
But when I write, I am the
first one to create the book
for children, and I
like it very much.
I like this work, because
inside me, being a very,
very grown-up grandmother,
I can still feel this
little girl that I was once.
So when I see children,
somehow, I can understand them
and maybe this is the reason
that children like my books.
So I start to read it, and excuse
me again that I make English,
it's not so good as your teachers.
One morning a little
girl named Prudence got
up on the wrong side of bed.
She felt like something was
missing, and she was in a bad mood.
Did that happen to you
sometimes, you wake up
and that you are in a bad mood?
Like what should I wear
to the kindergarten?
What I would like to eat breakfast?
So she woke up, and she was
in a very, very bad mood.
And you see this little
dwarf beside her.
So this is my Krasnoludek
that I told you.
Okay, so she felt very bad, the
little girl, and Prudence's father,
it's time for breakfast,
after she brushed her teeth
and all those things and dressed
up, it was time for breakfast,
and Prudence father made
her a deluxe breakfast,
a wonderful breakfast.
He squeezed orange juice into a
glass, make toast, not too soft
and not too burnt, and spread
butter and strawberry jam on it.
He fried egg just right, so the yolk
was not too runny, and poured a mug
of hot chocolate, not too
watery and not too thick,
not too cold and not too hot.
You see the little dwarf
looking up the jar of the jam?
You see him?
You see the little
dwarf, Krasnoludek?
Ari will show you.
Okay? It was the most, the
most delicious breakfast ever,
but Prudence felt like
something was missing.
"What more could you want,
the moon and the stars?"
asked Prudence's father, but
as you know, it's impossible
to get the moon and stars.
They are very high in the sky.
It's impossible.
I said, it's impossible
to buy moon and stars.
Okay, in a bad mood and grumpy,
Prudence went to kindergarten.
At kindergarten, Miss Zelda let
Prudence feed of the bunnies.
She was the kindergarten teacher.
You see the little dwarf again?
Where he's hiding?
In her pocket?
This is the one, when I brought you.
Miss Zelda made her queen for a day.
Miss Zelda asked Prudence
to show her how
to do a 100-piece jigsaw puzzle.
It was the greatest day in
kindergarten ever, but Prudence felt
like something was missing.
"What more could you want?
The moon and the stars?"
asked Miss Zelda.
Is it possible to get
moon and stars?
Is it possible?
You can get moon and stars?
It is impossible, believe me.
In a bad mood, grumpy, and
sad, Prudence went home.
At home, Grandma Scarlet
had made lunch.
Alphabet noodle soup.
You know alphabet noodle soup?
Salad without onions or pepper
and nonggreasy breaded cutlets,
mashed potatoes lumps, and
three flavors of Jello,
and you see the little dwarf
also, leaning on the -- to see it?
Do you see him, Krasnoludek,
leaning there?
You see? I will put him here.
He will be comfortable.
You can see both of
us at the same time.
And then it was the most
scrumptious lunch ever.
Prudence ate it all up
and said, "Thank you."
But she felt like something
was missing.
"What more could you want,
the moon and the stars?"
asked Grandma Scarlet.
In a bad mood, grumpy, sad, and
upset, Prudence went to play
with her friend, Charles.
Charles showed her his room.
Charles showed her his
most secret drawer.
Do you see little Krasnoludek there?
Do you notice him?
You can see him?
Yes? Ari, can you show it, the
little Krasnoludek is sitting there.
Okay, and later on Charles
played jet rocket with her.
You see the little
Krasnoludek there?
You see him riding in the car?
Playing with Charles was the most
exciting ever, but Prudence felt
like something was missing.
"What more could you want?
The moon and the stars?"
asked Charles.
Do you see the little
dwarf, Karsnoludek,
sitting on the back of the cat, huh?
Grandpa Emerson Walden let
her ride back in Bronco.
Grandpa Emerson Walden told
her stories of the old days.
This was usually what
grandparents tell grandchildren.
Being with Grandpa Emerson
Walden was the most fun ever,
but Prudence felt like
something was missing.
"What more could you want?
The moon and the stars?"
asked Grandpa Emerson Walden.
In a bad mood, grumpy, sad,
upset, gloomy, and blue,
Prudence went to her room.
In her room, Prudence imagine
seeing [inaudible] Prudence
like was the Peter Pan.
Do you see the little dwarf?
You can only see his head.
In her room, Prudence
was Captain Hook.
You know who is Captain Hook?
You know about Peter Pan and
Captain Hook, and this story?
And the room, Prudence
built a tower up to the sky.
The games in her room were the most
wonderful ever, but Prudence felt
like something was missing.
Then knock-knock, knock-knock,
knock-knock, somebody knocked
on her door, and in
walked Prudence mother.
Prudence mother saw Prudence in bad
mood, grumpy, sad, upset, gloomy,
blue, and down the dumps.
The worst thing in the world is for
a little girl to be down the dumps,
blue, gloomy, upset, sad,
grumpy, and in bad mood.
"You had better come
here right this minute!"
said Prudence mother,
gathering Prudence in her arms
and hugging her very tightly.
Now I must hug somebody.
I must hug -- you want
to come to me?
You, hey, hoo-hoo, hoo-hoo.
You want to come here?
Want to? Who want to
come to me to be hugged?
Okay, come on, come
on, quickly, quickly.
Run up. Run up.
Quickly, quickly.
Come over, come over.
Please, please, please.
Hi, what's your name?
>> Olivia.
>> Alona Frankel: Oh, Olivia.
I know a book about Olivia.
Can I hug you?
Okay. You had better come here right
this minute, said Prudence mother,
gather Prudence in her arms
and hugging very tightly.
It was the not the moon.
It was not the stars.
It was the fullest moon
and the starriest sky ever,
because the best thing that
can happen to somebody is
that you love somebody
and is hug, isn't it?
When someone's hugging you, and
I am a grandmother that like
to hug her grandchildren,
and when I see a child,
I always have this feeling
that I want to hug you.
So this is the story,
and here, also,
you can see this little
-- isn't he wonderful?
Isn't he? The little Krasnoludek.
Can you say Krasnoludek?
>> Krasnoludek.
>> Alona Frankel: Fantastic!
Wow! Beautiful.
So in no time, you can learn
Polish, which is not necessary.
Oh, it's so nice.
You can go to your place.
Okay, this is this
book about children
that sometimes they feel bad
and they do not really want,
they do not really know what
they want, but for sure,
they always want to be hugged.
Isn't it? And it's a cat here,
and you see the little
dwarf here and the cat.
Who has a cat at home?
Yeah? You have a cat?
>> I don't.
>> Alona Frankel: No?
>> A dog.
>> Alona Frankel: A dog.
Ah, yeah.
>> His name Jordon.
>> Alona Frankel: I see.
I see. So this is this
book I wrote about a girl
that felt bad, and this is me.
This is my picture.
It's like five or 10 years ago.
I looked much younger,
but never mind.
You still can recognize me.
Okay, so now [inaudible].
So now [inaudible].
Okay, so now I tell you
this story, and I told you
that the books do not grow
on trees, and I told you
that every book you see in the
world, many people created,
and I told you that the first one
that is responsible for a book to be
in the world is the
person that write the book,
and the second one is the person
that make the illustration
in the book.
And then the ones that make the
paper to print and the printer,
and the one that makes the cover.
And then the librarian
who invites you
to this amazing, beautiful library.
It's your first time here?
You have never been here?
>> No, I've been here
with my nanny before.
>> Alona Frankel: Wonderful, so
many, many people try very much
to create books for
children, and now I am sure
that most of you like books.
You like best?
Yes?
>> I have books in my room.
>> Alona Frankel: You
have books at your room?
Do you remember one that you can
mention that you have in your room?
>> I have -- I have
the Olivia fairy book.
>> Alona Frankel: That you like?
>> From the bookstore.
>> Alona Frankel: I see.
I see, and do you come
to the library often?
You're such a nice girl.
Olivia, Olivia, it's
a book about Olivia?
You know the book?
>> I have one in my room.
>> Alona Frankel: Oh, really?
Olivia. That's fine, okay,
Olivia, now you can run and sit
in your place, and maybe
-- thank you for coming.
Thank you very much.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
You can shake hands.
Thank you very much.
And I want you to remember my name.
It's Alona.
Can you say Alona?
>> Alona.
>> Alona Frankel: And now,
maybe some of you want to ask me
about my work, about writing
for children and illustrating
for children and about my cat.
I have a cat and I have
a fish, a goldfish,
and I have this Krasnoludek.
Is there anybody that
wants to ask me something?
You want to?
Come here.
Quickly, quickly, quickly.
What is your name?
>> Matthew.
>> Alona Frankel: Matthew?
Okay, and you?
>> Mark.
>> Alona Frankel: And
what is your question?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Ah, You are the one
that likes alligators?
>> I like [inaudible].
>> Alona Frankel: I
see, okay and you?
You wanted to ask me?
>> I like...
>> Alona Frankel: Okay, and so
thank you very much for coming
and letting me hug you,
because I like to hug really.
Okay, go to your place, please.
Is it anybody that wants to
be hugged or to ask something?
You want to be hugged?
You have a question?
>> Yes, I see that your
books have been translated --
>> Alona Frankel: Come to me?
Yeah? You want to be hugged?
You want to be hugged?
[inaudible].
What was the question?
>> My question is I can see
that your book been translated
into many languages, and
do they change the names?
>> Alona Frankel: Yes, of
course they change the name,
because they usually pick some name
that is popular in this country,
and well, I do not quarrel
about it, because in Korea,
they should pick a name is known and
loved, and also like in the Poland.
So, you know, so it's okay with me.
In Israel, I picked the name.
Also, in English I do, but in other
countries, I think they know best.
So I do not argue at all.
Well, I have such a good time.
Hi. You have a question?
>> I have a question.
Can you tell us a little more about
your little man that appears in each
and every page of the book?
Remember? [inaudible]
appear in the book?
So can you tell us of
the more about him,
for he came from, how he came about?
>> Alona Frankel: This
dwarf, this little dwarf.
Well, first of all,
this little dwarf,
his name is Krasnoludek,
and he came from Poland.
Poland is a country on the
other side of the world.
You know, the world is round, and
you in America and on this side,
and like here and Poland
is on the other side.
And usually, he lives in the woods,
and he helps people,
and he found me.
And he told that I am
a nice grandmother.
Do you I am a nice grandmother?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
I have all the equipment to.
So he decided to stay with me and
keep me company, and I use him,
his presence, in many books.
I put him like in this book.
Well, I don't know.
We do not have here,
but many, many books.
And then, you know, we shall give --
I brought them books about the moon
and the stars, and every one of
you is getting a present, a book.
So when you come home, you can tell
your parents about our meeting,
and this lady, that
she is a grandmother
and about the little dwarf that his
name is Krasnoludek, and you make me
so happy to listen to
me and now to hold you.
Really. Thank you very much.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
It's melting my heart, really.
I can't resist it.
It's so moving, you know?
Because you know, like I told
you, everyone that is writing
for children and illustrating,
he remembers himself
being a little child.
So when I see children -- so it's
really very, very moving for me.
So do we have some other questions
about Krasnoludek and you know,
always, he has this red
cap, and those trousers,
you can take them, but they won't.
He will be embarrassed.
And those red socks.
Okay, you have some question?
You want to come to me?
You would like to come to me?
Please.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Go ahead, go ahead.
But it's hot here.
Let me take you're, okay, off.
I will open.
Now it's difficult.
No, I can't.
What your name?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Ah! Such a --
>> I have a [inaudible].
>> Alona Frankel: Really?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Really?
>> Yeah.
>> Alona Frankel: And you
have some books also at home?
Very good.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Okay, you want to shake my hand?
>> Can you shake her hand?
>> Can you shake her
hand, Frederick?
>> Alona Frankel: High five?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Who else wants to be hugged?
Yes?
>> She has a question.
>> Alona Frankel: Yeah, okay.
You want to be hugged?
Okay, come on.
Come along.
>> She has a question.
>> Alona Frankel: A question?
Well, I am all ears, and I listen.
And this girl wants -- come, come.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Ah, really?
And you? And -- oh, come.
What is your question?
Do you remember?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Me too. Thank you.
It's from a city by the
name of Venice in Italy,
also on the other side of the
world, and it's made out of crystal,
and it's like bubbles, like
you blow bubbles, isn't it?
But I have only one,
and I like it very much.
If I many, I would give to
everybody, but have only one.
Thank you.
>> I have a question, Alona.
When did you know that she
wanted to write children's books?
>> Alona Frankel: Well,
in the beginning I only --
you can go to your
place, and thank you.
Thank you.
You too, okay?
>> I want to touch this.
>> Alona Frankel: You want
to touch my Krasnoludek?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Good so, I want to read
for you another book,
because we still have time.
If you -- you want to read
another book or you are too tired?
>> I want you to read another book.
>> Alona Frankel: Okay, good.
So this book is about manners.
You know, sometimes
when you get something.
So your parents say,
oh, say thank you.
Isn't it they asked
you to say thank you?
And if you do something wrong,
so they say please say excuse me.
So I wrote a book about manners.
How much it is important
to have good manners
and not to bother other people.
And about the question you asked,
yeah, when I started to draw,
to illustrate and write for
children, I will tell you later.
Okay, so this book
is a book of manners.
Here all the book is
full of cats and not --
the dwarf is not appearing here.
So the book was like this.
Hello, I am Joshua's mother.
I want to tell you about
Joshua and about manners.
Joshua is a little boy.
Good manners are things to do and
say that make it nicer for people
to live together, and
that is very important.
Nobody is born with good manners.
People learn good manners.
Joshua, for example, was born
without any manners at all.
As soon as he came into the world,
he made wee-wee all over the nurse.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
Oh, my, oh, my.
Later, when Joshua was a tiny
baby, his manners were tiny too.
Babies can't talk, so whenever
Joshua was hungry or lonely or help,
he would sob and cry and scream
and yell, and I, his mother,
did what I could for him with
all my love and patience.
And here he is screaming,
waah, waah, waah, waah.
His behavior wasn't perfect either.
During meals, Joshua would spit
out his food and make big mess.
Later, when Joshua was a little
bigger, he would reach out his hands
and demand this, that, this, that,
and I, his mother, did what I could
for him, with all my
love and patience.
The bigger Joshua grew, the
better his manners become.
Joshua learn to say three
beautiful, useful, magical words.
Please and thank you.
From that day on, my
life was changed.
Everyone likes it when his
or her help is appreciated.
Even mothers, even I, Joshua's
mother, please, thank you.
You know how to say thank
you and please, yes?
I am sure you know how to.
Joshua's table manners
have improved, too.
He has learned to sit
close to the table,
to eat with spoon all by himself.
He even leaves fewer crumbs.
Now Joshua knows a
lot of polite words
and uses them most of the time.
In the morning he says -- what
do you say in the morning?
Good morning, and in the
evening, before going to bed,
he says good night, yeah?
Good night.
When his friend, Charles,
comes to visit,
does Joshua say, "Enjoy your meal"?
No, no, no, no, no.
He's not saying that.
He says, "Hello, and welcome."
And when his friend,
Charles, is ready to leave,
does Joshua say, "You look nice"?
No, you say to his
friend, you look nice
when he's dressed in new clothes.
Joshua say, "Goodbye.
Goodbye, see you soon again."
When Joshua accidentally stepped on
Zelda, the kindergarten teacher's,
foot, did he say "Congratulations"?
No, he doesn't say this.
He says, "I am sorry."
You know this word, I am sorry?
Yeah? When Joshua's grandmother,
my mother, gives him a present,
does he say, "Good luck"?
No, he says thank you.
Whenever he gets present,
Joshua say thank you.
When Joshua wants me, his
mother, to read him this book,
does he say, "Bless you"?
No, no, no, no.
He says please when he wants me,
his mother, to read him this book.
Joshua say please.
When I, his mother,
finish reading this book
to him, Joshua says thank you.
Joshua's table manners
are really splendid now.
He can sit close to the table,
use a spoon and fork and a knife,
and wipe his mouth with a napkin.
He does not a mess with lots of
crumbs all over the table anymore,
and at the end of the meal, he
says, "Thank you, how wonderful."
And I, his mother, am
very happy and proud.
Now let me ask you a question.
If you wanted to read this book
to you again, what would you say?
"Yes please," or perhaps,
"No, thank you."
And I look at you now and I
feel that you are already tired.
Isn't it? And I think that
you will say to me thank you,
Grandma Alona Frankel, that you
write and illustrate those books.
You want to sleep, and I hope when I
meet you again, you will be already
in school, the first grade, and I
look at you, and you are all so nice
and beautiful, and I wish you
have a wonderful, healthy,
and happy life in the future.
Thank you for coming,
and you are sweet.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.